[Music]
welcome back certified country I am
Sophie she lazy with Brett Eldredge
today hello thank you for having us
Brett Eldredge is gearing up for a major
2018 he's hitting the road with Blake
Shelton for the country music freaks to
her this month and later this spring
he'll take the long way around on his
own very first headlining tour I caught
up with Bratton Nashville over the
holidays to talk all about it but let's
be real what I really wanted to ask
about was Edgar don't we talk about
Edgar's social media following yeah who
manages his social media account I do I
just kind of run with it I was just now
starting to really like try to get more
on there he's very human-like of a dog
he does the weirdest goofiest things and
yeah kind of matches my personality it's
really strange yes a people who look
like their dogs and I cried your dogs I
think that's a pretty spot-on at town
what's the best part about having Edgar
on the road with you I hate walking up
stage and going to an empty bus you know
it's all we're saying because use this
high energy and you go to a bus there's
nobody on there
well then I gotta ger and he's that he's
sitting there waiting for me on the bus
sit on the couch and I mean I was so
psyched this is like but now he sees me
during the show cuz I've been bringing
him out on stage and he does a trick on
stage it's pretty awesome
does he love it how does he deal with
the crowd I got him ear protectant and
so like loud noises won't get to him and
he gets a treat when he goes out says
you this trick where he flips the treat
over his nose and catching his mouth
it's pretty incredible and he nails it
almost every time and he loves to get on
stage now cuz he knows he's gonna get a
treat well him yeah I love he's in the
show biz for sure now you and I have
talked about this before but mean to me
it was the song that I danced yes my
first dance at my wedding so it's super
super special to me
dancing slow boy it fallens how you feel
and perfect what you see then not be
what you mean
[Music]
what does lovesong 101 with Brett
Eldredge what's kind of going through
your mind when you are getting in that
mode I've read a lot of love songs I
think I've read it from a lot of
different perspectives whether it's you
know hoping for love what I think it
would be the perfect scenario I love
what I see in people that are in love
but you know all these different ways
it's the world language you know and so
if you don't want to be cheesy with it
what you want to be sweet you want to
you want to have cooler you went up part
in it how do you know when it's too
cheesy if I play it back and I get to
the Willys Mike feel weird about it but
I'm like I can't sing that on stage
every night I'll feel real strange I got
a good cheese cheese meter it's running
high I just trashed the song
[Music]
that video is so cute Thank You Sadie
Robertson tell me how you and her got
together I had seen her social media and
I just thought she had an amazing spirit
she was sweet and and just an energy
that was so you know so much passion I
thought you know this is a girl that has
so much heart do you want this is the
kind of girl you want to take home and
and you know meet the fam she was all
about it and and and it just was a
magical magical shoot are you guys buds
now we are sure all right now before I
wrap it up I want to do something that
we do with everybody on the show called
the country quickie first concert you
ever attended Nelly Nelly I was
definitely one of them at least first CD
you ever purchased I think it was Garth
Brooks that's a good one
or MC Hammer I wanted to just swing it
goes right to Green Day
[Music]
it's all currently spinning on repeat I
don't know what now but I feel it's too
happy over now about I feel it still
feel it cell by Portugal the man if you
were not an artist you'd probably be
doing what fishing but I want to get
paid enough for that so tell me one
thing we would never guess by looking at
you
I'm sure know a little bit are you I'm
like I'm both loved being around people
but I also need that time to just go
chill and go to an island or something
and just disappear off the face there
for a while and come back and be crazy
me again